welcome back to PJ CH Design This is PJ
today I would like to show you how to
create this pyramid shape of a ring or
it could be a bracelet and how to
arrange the stone on it are you ready
let's get
started before we started the project
let's take a look on this finish piece
you can see each of the Finish piece is
done by one of those component and polar
array and the key is how we arrange
those three stone properly without you
know jamming into each other because
your JW does need some space to set the
stone so we're going to talk about
everything the detail for this tutorial
that's starting from the scratch like
most of the Ring tutorial always
starting with the ring size so go ahead
to use a circle and do exactly ring size
that you wanted to do um and then we're
going to starting design the element
here it depends on how big of the
element that you want it to have before
we do that we want to actually take a
look on the stone we're going to use you
can bring in the stone uh to start with
this is like8 mm if you need a stone it
is in the description below uh sign up a
news later then you can download a stone
with this Stone right here I need to
know what the arrangement is going to be
right so we are going to have one here
in the middle and the other two uh it's
going to be next to it ideally the
distance in between here for example I'm
going to mark it in between roughly here
and here you want them to be like a 0.1
uh millimeter roughly if it is more than
0.1 mm it might not to uh reflecting
each other nicely so we want to roughly
have a 0.1 mm and you don't want to make
it like way too small because your stone
may not be exactly size and you make you
make crash the stone so let's go ahead
to measure one more time something close
to here and here and
roughly oh that's a 0.05 see sometime
you can enlarge you know it's so zooming
so much you feel like oh you know I have
this this is is a really big gap in fact
they are not they are tiny all right so
then I have that there let me see
roughly there and 0.1 mm and then I'm
also going to mirror to the other side
something like this so this is our Stone
Arrangement all right once you have this
you're going to coming into the side
just draw a small straight line right
there it doesn't have to be long and
then we got going to pipe it in this
case I'm going to give it a try for like
a 6 mm in diameter SO3 in the radius and
we'll get something like that now notice
that this is A8 mm
stone8 is super big actually let's do4
so 2 mm in the radius and that will be
our prong now keep in mind that anything
smaller than the 04 I don't recommend it
it's because your PR might be break and
so that is the smaller size I will get
for my prong and I'll try to get in as
much as possible I but I don't want a
stone to cut it out both side and in
fact let me change the stone into the
red color it's easier for you to see all
right so I got one prong here ideally if
I draw a straight line in between here
and here you want the prong fitting uh
try to fit the prong within that line
possible um if not stick it out just a
little bit that's fine all right I also
need a one right in the middle something
look like that even they are cover on
the three stone and also wanted to have
one there you don't want to cut it more
than 20% of your prong it might break
right so we're going to make a copy
there and to be symmetrical just miror
to the other
side and then we also need a one over
here roughly like this and you want to
make sure that one is to align on the
right side of this guy right here
here all right eyeball is always not
super accurate I wanted to make sure
that they are accurate so you always
using aign tool all right so then we
also need to mirror that to this guy to
the other side so this is roughly the
stone Arrangement that we are going to
have once you have that just group them
all right we're going to use this to
determine the size of our metal part so
I'm going to move moving this one up
just put it there and then the second
things I wanted to do is to create this
pyramid right there so snapping to the
zero right here and I'm kind of guessing
how big that is maybe like this and then
this is deciding how tall you want it to
have you don't want it to have a twooter
it's not so comfortable all right and I
want to rotate it back for 45°
all right so this will be our pyramid
and then we're going to move in up
roughly here remember that when you have
all the way from the ring shank to the
tip that's how thick this ring is going
to be after we get that one I will
suggest you pick up the very last uh
phases look at my perspective you pick
up the very last faces and holding the
control and shift and click on this one
then you see your Gumball will have a d
we wanted this dot extended so extruded
that surface extend it all the way past
the ring shank right so let's take a
look if this Stone will fit it there
we're going to moving a stone on this
side and we are going to using a rotate
tool we do not want to copy we just
wanted to rotate it into this angle
right
here and then we wanted to put it inside
roughly like this for it to sitting a
little bit all right now if you take a
look on this we'll see okay this look
like it's like fitting really well but
don't get fooled by the arrangement of
what we have here because when you have
something like this you always need to
have a age a little bit and this will be
appear too small so in fact I need to
make them slightly bigger right um and
then we're going to move in this back up
because we cannot change the stone size
but we can change the metal size on the
design if you do not want a stone to be
so wide then make sure you are having a
smaller gemstone all right now we have
this one there we want a stone sitting
roughly something like this so we got a
little bit room outside all the way
around the stone something like that so
we can bright cut maybe moving it down a
little bit more something like that okay
so that look good and then we could
giveing a little fillet and so I'm going
to give a fillet edges let me lck in
this one first to show you when I fited
the edges and you don't need to have
something really big so that's A2 mm and
I wanted to fit it everywhere by the
bottom because we don't actually need
the bottom to be fitted uh we just need
the one on the top once you have that I
wanted to give you a test to see how
that look when you have a multiple so I
simply just going to rotate it's the
center and we're going to rotate it from
here to here make sure copy equal yes
this is just to try out what is it going
to look like right and then we're going
to have one here all right so then you
want to take a look and see if that work
well well before we do that I'm also
going to mirror that stone setting to to
the other side like this and then we're
going to select everybody and we're
going to rotate it give it a try and see
how that look when you have bunch of
them
together all right so as long as the
prong is not touching that'll be great
uh you can also set on the other side if
you want to all right but this is the
part that you want to pay attention all
right so that part look good and then
we're going to group everybody all right
and and then what we wanted to do here
is to doing the polar array but keep in
mind that it may not be 100% fitful
exactly what was the position that we
want so we wanted to Polar array with
the history on so we can adjust it so
let's go ahead to using the polar array
snapping into the zero I don't know how
many maybe
14 and see how that goes okay so 14 you
have a little bit G there depends on how
you like it some people like it some
people don't if you don't you want to
add up one more for 15 and 15 is
actually not too bad it's not it's not
touching there but I'm going to record a
history and show you what you can also
adjust right if you like don't like them
to touch that much you only things you
need to do is moving up a little bit so
then they will have a more Gap that's
why we want this past the when we
extruding the bottom we want to pass the
ring shank so if you move up I'm going
to move up a lot so you're going to have
a l more Gap in between if you move it
down closer to the center then it will
get closer so it really depends on how
you like on the look and also how much
thickness that you wanted to have there
all right so once you have that and then
you think this is good let's take a look
on the render always double make sure to
checking on the render and see if that
is what you want um because you may look
like okay that's look okay but in fact I
may want to get it closer so I may want
to moving in just a little bit more all
right so then I don't have this dipping
that much all right so if that is what
you want let's go ahead to pick up our
ring Rail and we're going to extrude
planner curve straight both are equal
yes and then we're going to pick up
everybody and then we are going to bow
in different
all the ring all of this
guy I hope you enjoy the video and learn
something new today leave in the comment
let me know how you like it I know it is
frustrating when you try to find your
technical questions online and you
cannot find a perfect video on YouTube
if you are ready to the next step I
would like to help you together we'll
come up a study plan that will help you
to learn jury care faster without all
the frustration check the link below all
you need to do is fill out the phone to
let me know what is your challenging on
learning jewelry cat hope to see you in
the section thank you for watching and I
will see you next
[Music]